well chris damon congratulations you
guys are moving forward in the third and
final round of our competition now
gentlemen this last round we're gonna be
sending you back to your home forges to
build one of three iconic weapons from
our fortune fire vault
we've got the pawn dot
the boazondae
and the kelawang
a gentlemen we got to keep with the
casino theme so we're going to spin the
wheel of forging again
but here's the deal if you don't like
where you land you have an option to
press your luck and spin again
but
those four days total to 35 hours
if you choose to spin again we're going
to be deducting two hours from that
total time
ready to find out where you're building
at home let's do it do it chris you're
up first
all right
all right chris you landed on the pawn
dot how you feeling i'll keep it i don't
want to get that thing
the pandat is a two-handed war sword
native to the dayaks of borneo in
indonesia exclusively used in combat the
weapons single edge blade was uniquely
angled and featured a wide flat tip the
ornate design made it very effective
lethal weapon delivering devastating
chops through the armor of an opponent
the sphere sword was featured in season
3 of fortune fire with the smiths both
turned in beautiful weapons but
ultimately the better balanced blade won
the title dame you ready
let's go
the kelawang
so of course i get the kellowing
i don't have a quench tank that would
fit something like that the odds of it
landed on kellowing again are not too
high so i'm willing to bet to get one of
the other two
hit me again all right that means we're
going to be taking two hours off your 35
hours you will have 33 hours to build
whatever i land on
the boazonda you happy with it oh yeah
the bola sandy sword is a central
african weapon that features a long
pierced ricasso and a wide leaf shaped
blade that tapers to a steep sharp tip
the razor sharp edges were designed to
deliver devastating stabs and slashes
into an enemy the bobo sande was
previously seen in season seven of
fortune fire
where while both smiths face challenges
achieving the width of this weapon
victory went to the lighter more
comfortable sword
all right chris you're going to have 35
hours to build your pawn dot damon
you've got 33 hours to build your
boazande gentlemen don't forget these
are high stakes the house is putting up
ten thousand dollars in the title of
forge of fire champion for the winner
good luck we'll see you in four days
good luck man good
my name is chris gardner i am 37 years
old from las vegas nevada
i'm doing a sword with 327 layer billet
looks like i have enough steel i'm
pretty happy with how it's going it's
looking pretty good so far something
goes wrong with a quench that could
basically destroy my blade
planning for the worst hoping for the
best
all right here we go i get it over to
the quench tank
and
it comes out straight
that's good
hard this blade is a little awkward it's
a weird shape i need a
specific edge on this thing that's going
to hold up during these tests and still
stay sharp
damond he's an excellent smith can't
wait to see what he brings but you know
i hope mine's just a little bit better
my name is damon clark i am 45 years old
started doing brazilian jiu jitsu about
12 years ago so i think that part of the
reason i'm a pretty decent bladesmith is
the discipline and the strength it takes
to be in jiu jitsu it's looking good so
far i'm gonna draw out the basic blade
shape for now i gotta worry about
getting parameter lengths we'll just see
how how things go so 243 layers that's
what i was shooting for i really like
the look of bronze so i'm going to put a
bronze guard and pommel so i've got my
pommel tapped and now i need to
thread my tang
shoot i don't think this is going to
work
i see that the threads are not right
with the threads as shallow as they are
it's not going to grab the pommel and
it's not going to be tight i build a new
pommel i get it on the handle everything
looks good it's tight well it's going to
work just fine now i'm ready to start
moving forward it looks great the the
pattern's really showing really well now
it's time to get the final edge on it
and get this sucker sharp
losing two hours didn't really change my
plan of action she's a winner i feel
really good about what i made
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
i'm gonna take your weapon and deliver
some lethal strikes on this big carcass
because these are two different kinds of
weapons with different designs they may
cut differently or perform differently
but overall the feeling and the way i
wield them should be the same chris
you're up first ready for this yeah
let's do it
all right chris let's talk about your
pandat here when i picked it up it felt
so light a little forward heavy but
that's what it's supposed to be because
it's a chopper your handle construction
is smooth i can fit both hands perfectly
there no extra space overall serve with
a function of a chopper like this
you will kill
thank you
damon you're up next you ready sir yes
sir
all right damon let's talk about your
bow with zombie here your handle
construction fits my hand perfectly i
like the palm swell there because it
locks my hand in
your edges are sharp they cut deeply and
thrust nicely into this carcass overall
sir your bowl of zombie
you will keel
welcome to our strength test the
porcelain pot chop
it's gonna be a lot of fun to see what
your blades do to the pots but i'm more
concerned about where the pots do to
your blades and their edges chris you're
up first you ready to go yes
i'll take it
chris you survived good job
you got a little bit of glinting and you
got a couple slight rolls but they're
very minimal everything's still straight
sharp sturdy
good job
thank you
damon you ready to go can we just talk
this out
oh
[Music]
dammit you survived good job
some minor glinting a couple of little
rolls in the edge but it's still overall
a very sharp blade nice job thank you
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test divine slice
to find out how sharp your weapons are
i'm going to take your weapon and slash
you these vines chris you're up first
you ready i'm ready great
all right chris let's talk about your
panda here
your edges
easily cut through the vine sir overall
your pandat you will cut thank you
all right damon the final gamble are you
ready sir yes sir let's do this
all right damon the edges are sharp and
cut cleanly through the vines
your weapon too sir
you will cut thank you
well well well
both of your weapons performed extremely
well in all three of our tests
but in this competition we have to have
a winner which means one of you has to
go home and the winner of today's
fortune fire competition is
chris congratulations
now damon unfortunately your blade just
didn't make the cut and jay's going to
tell you why
damon you got everything the world would
be proud of they tested equally fit and
finish and the finer details is what it
came down to and chris just squeaked a
little bit ahead of you that's it cool
damon up against any other blade it
would have won but unfortunately did not
come out with the win today i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off the
forge floor man thanks for having me
guys good job buddy
i know that with what they told me about
my weapon that there really wasn't a
loser here
i'm taking home just a fantastic
experience this competition is amazing
i am humbled by this it's been wonderful
chris you are the fortune fire champion
and you're gonna be taking home a check
for ten thousand dollars man
congratulations ah thank you guys thank
you so much i'm like in disbelief this
title of fortune fire champion means a
lot to me it's something that i can
always take with me
i am the fortune fire champion
you